it's crazy cuz like I wouldn't when you  did the batter I was like yeah I forgot  like you like launched Chris Brown bro  like you had his first single like that  nobody knows that artists are gonna be  where they end up going right and Chris  Brown at that time is was 16 years old  he was just turning 16 just turned in 16  years old and you're the one of the  biggest producers in the world at the  time like what did you see that in him  like earlier was it just like for you  just like another placement my kid  nah man like I made him a promise the  day I met him I was like you know I'm  making you a number one song right now  and like I just had a feeling like he  just seemed like for its time the new  Michael Jackson like kid was dancing cuz  had a crazy ass voice that age and I  could tell his whole personality style  and everything I knew he was gonna go  and especially since the people that  brought in there one of them was Mark  Pitts you know right I discovered like